great screen and harden
one of the best in the business flynn
has eight
[Music]
no check that they have nine as well
harden lobs it up
claxton tips it in somehow he let it go
there was one second on the clock
he's played almost 12 first half minutes
he's dealing with harden now
and hart with a left hand
boy he's so good with the ball quinn
yeah because he i mean chris
he handles it so well puts so much
pressure on you
man game lets the three fly it is off
the rim and hardens
jordan running
now that's who challenged levert on the
shot and it was jordan
pacer's offense much more efficient to
start this third quarter than what we
saw in the second
they scored just 21 points brown in the
lane
and there's hardin again he had the
right idea but he didn't
recognize that brooklyn was gonna have
three people waiting for him when he got
there
and that goes in mcconnell
yeah you could see him get him on the
arm they were able to take advantage
when
pardon was off the bench remember they
built that 16 point leads on clacks
that was going to be tough yeah because
claxton was able to get into him
and make it to the other end
and claxton has nine again the little
box in one zone
underneath the man-to-man by mcconnell
and you can see harden looking to take
advantage with his size
working on joe harris that patented step
through won't fall
nick claxton the hustle battling for the
board
james harden full head of steam layup
goes
because it opens up an opportunity for
your team at the other end and you see
it with james hart
to the three-minute mark we go
and hart with a left hand got it man he
is
just he is hard to deal with
johnson oh and it goes
right right past everybody's
a 36 point night for james harden
five-time scoring leader
gets around brogdon puts it up and
and get it to the room the defense is
pretty solid somehow hardened
finds a way trickling off the clock
karis levert fires away
no good rebound james harden why is that
important
another triple triple-double for james
harden
eighth road win for the brooklyn nets no
kyrie irving tonight
no kevin durant the nets get it done
124 115 in indiana
the celebration from the bench between
kai
and kevin and those realizing that that
was the reason